Starkey's rule of revolutions is very
simple all they do is reproduce the
worst features of the ancien régime
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm constant in kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people are brilliant guests this week is
an author broadcast an eminent historian
dr. David Starkey welcome to
trigonometry hello oh I guess so
trigonometry is the three but mostly you
so I'm at the top of the hypotenuse we
normally like to get our guests to
introduce themselves but you're someone
who needs very little introduction so
why don't we just crack on with it we're
delighted to have you on the show
because I think the historical
perspective and we talked about this
before we started is fascinating because
we have such short memories nowadays and
I think it's very tempting memory
exactly nematode work and so many things
that are happening in society now the
trends whether it's woke culture whether
all of these things it's very tempting I
think for us particularly younger people
to assume that this none of this has
ever happened before this excessive
introspection this navel-gazing
obsession with ourselves and with
individualism but give us a historical
perspective as a historian looking at
modern society what do you see and what
do you think back to in history when you
look at what's happening and I do a
little plug Oh am I on my way in here
I was reading the proof for my latest
article for this brilliant new magazine
of which I am a columnist the critic and
it's looking centrally at this
extraordinary man Jean Jacques also and
if we want a single source of why we are
completely [ __ ] up yes
inevitably of course he's French at
least every bad idea is French and
because they take the subject of ideas
and reason so
seriously and they as it were tear it
from the roots of experience and good
sense and general anglo-saxon lottery we
are so very good at on this side and and
also I think is the beginning of
virtually the list of nouns that you
gave the introspection the profound
sense of solipsism of self the absurd
belief in our own absolute importance
and that the thing that I mean the whole
origin of Diana fication do you remember
this ancient figure Princess Diaries all
of that is pure pure Rousseau but what I
think we've got to understand your
introduction was really interesting
about history what I think strikes me
and again I've been writing about this
in the context of politics is any from
point of view of when I was tortured on
I was a young man roughly at the time of
Noah's Ark we were taught very
definitely that history is then and we
are now and the drawing of the parallels
between the two of them is dangerous and
whatever but as I've got older and I
think it's partly you come to have a
history yourself so you've become very
very aware of your own change the
changes in your end times
your physical aches and pains and all
this kind of thing but what I can now
see is the extent of patterns and the
repetition of patterns and what I think
we can do if we put who so in let's put
wool so in context he is the immediate
run-up to the French Revolution and if
we look at the French Revolution
although you'll remember there's a
famous supposed remark of Chou Enlai
when he was asked and had the French
Revolution been a good thing or a bad
thing
and he's birthday responded it was too
soon I think he's wrong
we could see immediately the French
Revolution was an exceedingly bad thing
from which France has never recovered
what was it it's the beginning of our
modern politics the split between if you
like the liberal and the conservative is
the direct product of the French
Revolution because what the french
revolution does led above all by who so
though he's not the only one he's got
sort of partners and arms and people
like Voltaire although of course they
hated each other the left always hate
each other you can just look at the
Guardian at the moment and you get the
idea of the Labour Party the idea of the
bear pit it is and what big what they
begin by doing is deciding a bit like
Tony Blair in the second or third stage
of this process that history was a
mistake a bad thing
we needed to start from scratch and what
the French Revolution tries to do is to
invent society human relations the world
from scratch starting now at this
particular moment and we will simply
rethink everything and and we tried it
in Russia a couple who did exactly the
same with even were even worse even
worse consequence Starkey's rule of
revolutions is very simple all they do
is reproduce the worst features of the
ancien régime so you've just got a
particularly unpleasant but you've had a
succession of deeply unpleasant czars
China is run by a mad Emperor China's
always run by mad Empress and the
Communist Party has just replaced the
Mandarin aid but the the French
Revolution the French Revolution is that
is the key start of this process I mean
only you aware for example it's not just
that they tried to change politics you
can understand if you look at ancien
régime France why you want serious
political change do you know they try
try to change the calendar that they
decide we all know they invent the
metric system well sort of sensible
except has been made completely
redundant by computers why the Americans
still use feet in witches and but they
decide not simply to have 10 for measure
or ten four quantities they decide there
shall be ten hours in the day ten days
in the week ten months in the year
everything is given the new name they
decide that every geographical area in
France shall be obliterated and you
shall cover France with a network of
neat squares each one of which is
roughly the same size so you simply tear
the world apart
Yuri conceived human relations you
abandon religion you celebrate the
worship of Pure Reason and you finish up
with one of the great moments of
blasphemy in human history where you
have an actress who is no better than
she should be as my mother would have
said from the comedie francaise
enacting the gut part of the goddess of
Reason barely clad on the high altar of
not for a demure the world goes
completely mad and it goes up its own
bottom and the revolutionaries tear
themselves apart now what does that
sound like Twitter
it sounds like Twitter but it sounds
like something else
it sounds like what's going on on the
far left now have you just noticed this
moment in which that ghastly woman
Susanne more you know the one who wears
a kind of Chinese sort of shark's fin
soup as hair has been ostracized for
saying that women are being a woman as a
biological fact so the entire and in Rae
333 people will who'd have thought that
the Guardian have 333 people working
from that was bigger than its readership
this is what you this is the only reason
the Guardian can do what it does is that
it doesn't matter if it doesn't serve a
single paper it's run exquisitely by an
offshore trust if you know I'm tax free
offshore program and how deeply you can
only be progressive if you're rich it's
it's a corporate equivalent of a
trustafarian anyway but he's
disappearing up its own bottom or
because it's not a bottom of course that
would be if it were gay rights one
imagines it's is it because it's trans
rights I'd presumably only it so called
the site vagina
and and the left is just going up itself
but it does it every does it as a cycle
and it's really striking so you have
that first cycle of liberalism in the
1790s then you've got a second one in
the 1840s with here in Britain which is
the the second great revolution which is
the Industrial Revolution which again
dissolves human relations in exactly the
same way I mean come on you two have you
read you read Marxist communist
manifesto or believe me I have tell me
the great bit in which he says what the
bourgeois do what what does the new
bourgeois sensibility do I feel like I'm
in a history sort of a rat torture
waiting for you yeah yeah so what the
question is what what did what does Marx
and the Communist Manifesto say the
bourgeoisie do they take advantage of
the working-class yeah but that a much
there's a wonderful passage in which he
describes them tearing off the draperies
that have made life acceptable the the
relation of the holiness of the church
the dignity of chivalry that they strip
everything of of of tradition of respect
of value in other words it's a new way
of starting the world from scratch and
that of course creates our modern
politics in Britain it's from the
outcome of that that you get the Liberal
Party on the one hand and the
Conservative Party on the other so you
and then your globalization
and the increased madness of the left is
the third wave of that so we're just
going through this sequence of waves and
they all end the same way they all go up
themselves do you think we're in quite a
dangerous place David because we don't
have a coherent opposition to our
present government and isn't that quite
dangerous thing for societies I don't
think the government in that sense much
mutters in this story at the moment I
mean we're in a very strange position
that you've got
the one hand in terms of the formal
political process as you say you've got
a government that in one sense just
occupies the field you've got a useless
opposition worse than useless opposition
on the other hand you've got so there's
a there's a dominance of a supposed
conservatism it's a very funny sort of
conservatism that's just spent about a
trillion pounds without thinking about
but never mind it calls itself but then
if you look at virtually every other
important institution from the BBC to
most of the press to the universities
you get a very very different picture
which is the dominance to a large extent
of this insane woke culture which is
there of course not necessarily because
people believe it some do but above all
because of corporate vanity and
indulgence I mean the reason in my own
University of Cambridge and is overrun
with this sort of stuff is you have an
absolutely useless vice-chancellor
needless to say is Canadian so pre-plea
name
stooop has only got to see a woke cause
to prostrate himself before it and you
see this with CEOs and whatever and you
know you just I mean if the Guardian
incident is a fascinating one one
employee who apparently as trans was
already resigned once then rights to the
Guardian to say that because of Suzanne
Moore's wicked column in stating that on
the whole women tend not to have beards
and penises and occasionally to
menstruate that he felt you know he or
she or Z felt oppressed and therefore
threatened to threaten to resign then
immediately 333 are people coming along
as well so there is this there is this
peculiar we've got a world in which
there is no opposition to the left
culturally and there's no opposition to
the right politically and the two groups
just continue walking past each other is
completely extraordinary but
with this work mentality and the fact
that as you say even though the far left
is not in power they have power oh
they're in social sorry they're a
different form yet exactly exactly
that's what I men's of power and again
you know the power of if you look at
they at the various forms of cultural
Marxism the argument was always control
education you know going back to the
jesuit give me give me the child for six
years and i've got them for life the
argument well education is outside the
public schools and to an extent even in
those is controlled by these values and
again what is really really striking
whether the view is the origin where
does child centered learning oh it's
true so i mean that saying is it is just
extraordinary and again the the you know
our politics driven by a celebrity i
better shot happened because i'm on in a
minor way and but our politics our
culture driven by celebrity russo is one
of the first celebrities russo pioneers
in the confessor I mean he pioneers the
tell all you know he's a Kardashian and
whatever I mean you know the the the the
revelation of all you know ones I mean
not not simply washing one's dirty wear
underwear in public but actually soiling
and holding it up for admiration he's
there he's at the heart of all of this
but let me ask you this question David
because as you know it's it's an apt
metaphor for the current moment as we
know with a virus you are likely to
catch it if it's around but your immune
system has to be compromised somewhat to
be susceptible to it so what is it about
the cultural moment that we're in and
again if the historical perspective here
is interesting because again it's not
the first time that it's a civilization
has been tempted to disappear up its own
bottom as you say what is it about the
cultural moment now that as a society we
seem to be susceptible to some of these
far left ideas how is it that we've come
to a place where
outrageously ridiculous concept seem to
be just regurgitated on the BBC without
any question without it it's a very good
question
I think that the 20th century was right
from the beginning if you go back to the
first world war the whole beginning of
modernism in aft of Dada and whatever it
was a kind of spitting in the face of
the past it was intended to be the
belief that the first world war
represented the death of an old wicked
world and and and you know you spat on
is something even nastier upon it which
is what Dada and all the rest of it was
about and that is run as a general theme
through the 20th century through the
anti art the brutality and architecture
the and again the way in which the 60s
consciously revived that immediate
atmosphere of the early 21st World War
the early 1920s so you know you get war
Howe rediscovering Dada the liberation
of the sixties the liberation movements
of the 60s consciously picking up from
again the Russian revenue that immediate
most revolutionary period in Russia it's
picking up and and you you you have this
is again it's this cycle of liberalism
the sixties notoriously gay of course
much needed that was attacked needed a
tiny mmm much that need that much that
needed changing was changed but once you
start that ball rolling that
everything's got to be changed that the
past has got to be discarded that all
that matters is the individual all that
matters are my feelings all that matters
is what I feel is right all that matters
is that I feel hurt do you see what I
mean it just it just rolls and rolls and
rolls and we can get away your question
and thinking think he might talking my
way to an answer
as I often do I think one of the reasons
we can do this and get away with it is
of course in every other way our lives
are better Sakura less threatened than
we've ever been
if you had a civilization where people
had to work harder where there were
deeper I don't mean what we call oh I've
been hours in the office look at what
you've actually double gobble-gobble
think of what the back-breaking labor of
a peasant or a coal miner was and so
we've got a society which protects and
indulges it's a society because we lead
such safe lives that we can get
ourselves many dare I said into the
current hysteria that we are about the
coronavirus in which can I gently say at
the moment of speaking 10 people out of
a population of 65 million in Britain
died 10 people I have to say by the time
this recording goes on the one thing
that is pretty clear it constantly is
yes if you look in England at the at the
onset of the plague in the 14th century
roughly a third of the population died
at the first bloom and then it rolls on
and on and on and by the minute by V but
by the end of the 14th century the
population of England is halfed and it
takes centuries we're not seeing that
and do you think that that's what we're
seeing the self-indulgence the
concentration on their feelings don't
you think that's very dangerous for a
society of course because it shows that
there's a lack of moral or sort of lack
of character a lack of fiber or what old
fashioned oh you make me feel so young
play playing the of course you're right
but we can get away with it for the
moment because virtually every other
Western society is the same but of
course over there there are societies
that are not that ain't true in Iran
that is not true in China and who knows
I mean we are it's very very easy and
and again you know civiles constantly
made the point civilizations disappear
and we were talking before we went on
air about that extraordinary moment of
the late 18th century and which again of
course is in his Rousseau whatever one
of the very very great figures of that
period is Edward Gibbon the historian
who writes about the death of a
civilization the decline and fall of the
Roman Empire and what he blames it on is
Christianity essentially he sees a
change of values achieve the any and of
course he sees Christianity as being
individualistic Pacific indulgent and
self-centered rejecting a notion of
military value once we are now and and
and you know societies can turn in on
themselves and clearly one of the one of
the remarkable things about Rome is that
having achieved this astonishing power
and dominance through and you know Roman
civilization really is pretty horrible
it suddenly turns against itself it
turns into something radically different
and falls well we are confronted with a
radical Islam on the one hand and a
radical different vision in China of a
regulated state controlled capitalism
run not by floppy classicists like Boris
John
but by ruthless properly trained
engineers in which the human being is
seen merely as a cog in the wheel not
the creature like us to be indulged in
every whim fantasy and hurt feeling you
look at how the thing was handled in
China and it you are just ordered what
you do yeah and if you step out of line
how many years in jail is it yeah if if
that but this is a thing that you talk
about the threats you know radical Islam
the rise of China with its very
different mentality and I think threats
have always existed and a strong healthy
civilization like a strong healthy body
is able to deal with external challenges
the thing that trouble what if you
decide you see so this is my point the
thing that troubles me is that if you we
weaken our own sense of ourselves of of
the value of our civilization in fact
we've done more than weaken it in fact
what is peculiar and it's a very it
striking I think it here again England
is from England I'm going to talk about
England England has been the country
that's led the way in virtually
everything we invented modernity in the
late 17th century the Industrial
Revolution and all the rest right and
one of the very peculiar features about
England which I think has become a kind
of disease which has spread to the rest
of the West is the self-hatred
in English intellectual I mean it's
written about very very interestingly by
George Orwell you'll remember that just
immediately before and well on either
side of the and the second world war in
which was that wonderful passage
describing the kind of people who read
The Guardian you know the sandal the
sandal-wearing quakerage classes veggie
or invariably vegetarian or vegan and as
the kind of people who would rather
steal from the poor box than stand to
sing the national anthem and that again
it goes back to the late 19th century
you've got in the Mikado's wonder in
Coco's song in The Mikado of all the
people that he hated it's those who it's
those who sing the praises of every
century but this and every country but
there
and this has become profoundly deep
rooted in anglo-saxon culture it was I
think essentially snobbery
I mean English roots utterly disgusting
you really really must eat French you've
got absolutely when you give an example
absolutely no sense of style or dress
you illustrate the answer and then of
course it becomes given an extra crank
and edge by race sensitivity and so it
now shifts from snobbery to something
else which is that we of course as
imperialists are responsible for
absolutely all the ills in the world and
then of course not only did we have an
empire we had slavery so every other
culture in the world including China
hadn't I did not have slavery and in
fact the peculiar thing about the
British Empire is that it may be built
on slavery but it then actually spends
more money on eradicating that it ever
made from it and then of course the
slavery you can then turn across the
Atlantic because until very recently
what was very striking about America was
right or left a passionate patriotism
but suddenly in America with race
politics and slavery you're using these
things to discredit even the American
ideal even the American Revolution even
the American Declaration of Independence
because of course the American
Declaration of Independence you know we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that men are born free and equal with
you know certain rights given by the
divinity and whatever by the Creator and
you have slavery so there is indeed a
fundamental hypocrisy and you're using
that and the left is using that to
devastating effect to lead to a
rejection of your own civilization and
to see it as being responsible for all
the ill in the world was the plain truth
is that the West and capitalism if you
value health if you value education if
you value secure
of life have created a civilization
which offers in compromise entity of the
population than has ever ever been the
case before but then you know what we
take it for granted and it's like a
religion because the way you talk about
it it's almost as if by being English
we're born into original sin it's a
brilliant Josh it's a serious
conversation see I think one of the
things we've got to understand is how so
much of what we're talking about now is
displaced religion now this is something
else which is utterly fundamental you
know G K Chesterton awful farting
fascist that's good farting fascist and
Roman Catholic that he was Brit but
brilliant brilliant writer and very
considerable poet has this wonderful
phrase about what happens when people
lose belief in God and the phrases you
don't believe in nothing you believe in
anything and what I think has happened
is in area after area what were
religious positions have been translated
into political positions being one of
the reasons why we're talking about
Twitter one of the reasons why Twitter
is so horrible of course is the work
culture has now become a new orthodoxy
and the woke leave another walk were
karate the Twitterati enforce it just as
though they were Dominican friars you
know as as as though they were Dominican
and inquisitors I mean and you know if
you actually look at when you get a
Twitter basting if those people could
burn you they would they would actually
in other words that that that we've that
far from a liberalisation of culture
we're enforcing a new Orthodox is a
religious word these are new articles of
faith and and again I think that one of
the reasons why will curry you don't
find much were curry in France women in
France are desperately trying to get
French men woke they're having a real
struggle and I've noticed no were curry
whatever in Italy or Berlusconi it
doesn't seem to me to have learned too
many lessons from the active immune me
too and all the rest why is that because
all of this liberalism that we are
talking about now in England and America
latches onto the back of of of
Puritanism and nonconformity that
immense self-righteousness that belief
that you are the elect that belief that
most of the rest of human beings are
deplorable people you know it's the
Salem witch trials they've got to be
whipped into line because they are
fundamentally wicked I mean the left
believes doesn't it that people with
little opinions like mine are
fundamentally wicked we don't just
disagree we are morally wrong and now
these are religious Basu are you seeing
what I'm trying to do and and I think
again this is why why is it were the two
cradles of Western civilization and
Britain and America are undergoing the
extent of the crisis that we are now we
invent Puritanism in this country thank
god we expect moat and export most of
them to America and the worst ones or
Northern Ireland Irish and American
viewers so for those of you is still
here how do you feel about Australian
French as well how do you feel about
Australia David before well then of
course undergoing exactly the same they
inherit that part of ours you see again
and I love all these countries I have a
house in America I adore musi I know
been to New Zealand but I adore
Australia and again it's because of the
uniqueness and completely remarkable
quality of the British Empire which is
after the catastrophe
remember Britain has only ever had one
defeat in the last 300 years and that is
the loss of the American colonists the
loss of the American colonies that made
everybody in Britain rethink and the
rethinking is led by the man who leads
the reaction to the French Revolution
invents modern conserve
by Edmund Burke and Burke argues that
the way that the the reason that things
went wrong in America was that we didn't
recognize we the British the king the
Prime Minister didn't recognize the need
that's built into being English
especially which is a sense of
self-government
the right going back to our Reformation
going back to Henry the eighth's break
with the Roman Church
the thing that's Dindin to or used to be
Dindin to you about being English was
the right to run your own affairs and of
course if you send a colony overseas and
the people who believe in their right to
run their own affairs by the time that
you've sorry would you like to drink by
the time you've got to the 1770s and
you've got a city like Philadelphia
which is about to overtake Dublin in
size which at that point is the second
city of Empire you know of course they
want to run their own affairs and you
get London trying to run it for them so
from that point onwards and you see
particularly in with the Durham report
in Canada the British government comes
up with this astonishing notion which is
unique in the history of Empire that we
should see all of these former colonies
Canada Australia New Zealand the white
ones and moving towards self-government
and the Empire consciously fosters
increasing self-government and so we are
in a better temper is unique in spawning
this series of Mirrors States not the
kind of fragments that had torn to
pieces of the Roman Empire has happened
after you know the the fall of the
Soviet empire or the Czarist empire but
these these consciously replicating
elements so and have you ever been to
Ottawa no I've never Ottawa it's totally
fascinating you look at the Canadian
Parliament building what architectural
style is it in this you know is in this
new world it's
gothic it's it's a gothic fantasy and
because the the the original one of the
1860s burnt-out is actually rebuilt in
Gothic after the first world war because
it's saying we are part of this same
world this is very difficult to believe
with with mr. Trudeau but really it is
part of this anglo-saxon world and
looking at the way our society then
curses to connect and then will snap
which are there again means that we seed
the virus of Puritanism and we seed the
virus of woke in it so alongside the
good bits through the bad bits which is
why as I said whoa Koreas essentially
anglo-saxon it's Australia is New
Zealand it's Canada supremely Canada and
being historian you can see and identify
patterns looking at the past and seeing
the patterns in the present have we
reached the end or do we have somewhere
to go and is the destination
particularly unpleasant and any
historian you've got to be Neil Ferguson
to pretend to do a deeply a door and it
but I'm not paid enough to take this
kind of risk the we don't know if people
thought they did I mean if you remember
after the fall of the Berlin Wall
there was one of the most famous and
sidious tess's of all time the end of
history by Francis Fukuyama taking his
title from Hegel the end of history the
triumph of the West the triumph of
liberal capitalism you know that the
liberal values on the one hand and the
capitalist system on the other hand
in-hand a social and economic freedom
would march into a sooner one of those
were a bit like Russian really start you
know all of these heroic figures against
the rising swell it didn't quite turn
out like that so how do we know but I do
think we should have learned one thing
from the collapse of that dream from the
rise of radical Islam from the mize
China and so on we should remember
vulnerability and again we've been able
to behave in the absurd fashions that we
are behaving now simply because our
world it seems so knowable it seems so
manageable
it seems so controllable it seems so
safe and one of the things that I hope
is now happening in this 20th century
and word in which you know every five
years it's there another time bomb
another bomb goes off blowing apart this
certainty that we will become a little
more aware of vulnerability then again
maybe this is just me getting out no I
don't think it is I'm not saying you're
not getting older we all my point is
that I think what's happening now with
the coronavirus and I understand that
you don't think you know I think no I've
just raised a question yes okay I just
raised my point is I think we are
starting to become aware that this
illusion of permanence safety of
permanent stability this is a point I've
been trying to make to people for a long
time if you want to remake society from
the ground up you've got to remember
it's going to be different you're not
going to be able to keep all those
things that you like and keep them and
take them for granted society will be
different I think one of the things that
people are becoming aware of just a
little bit with the coronaviruses this
for stability and this for security is
only four is only fake it's only
temporary it's only in person one again
that wonderful phrase describing the
French nobility in the years before the
Revolution that they were walking on an
abbess strewn with flowers yeah isn't
that rather great yes but you see in
other areas I think we are engaged in
what I would call diversionary panic I
mean I think much environmentalism
what I'm afraid in my course of moments
I call eco wank
with you know the great purveyors like
David Attenborough and grater and
whatever is is this again is the false
end of the world but you see again it's
religious yeah the the essentially I
mean you look at the figures involved I
mean David Attenborough is manifestly
a kind of New Testament prophet White's
true bringing down holy tablets from all
eyes and you Moses
and greater but she's just a mad child
Saint the Middle Ages was filled with
mad child saints but but that again the
end of the world you see it's a new form
it's a new form it's a new Christian
heresy it's a belief that were being
punished for wickedness the wickedness
of leading comfortable lives and that
again it's the belief that man is
sinning against nature
you turn nature into a goddess another
in this case now we're reverting the
medieval pantheism or pagan nature
worship or whatever it's all there all
these things are after and that sort of
thing seems to me to be just utterly
absurd and at the same time the much
more real threats they're being ignored
is also that that all sorts of academic
disciplines
I don't think of caught up or they're
part of the problem I think history has
become very much part of the problem
that the kind of discussion that I am
having with you now will be regarded
with absolute horror by 99% of my
historical colleagues if you actually
look at what goes on in university
history departments now it is more and
more my new analyses of little tiny
problems on the one hand or on the other
hand engaging with fashionable theories
about identity representation feminism
or whatever and it has it absolutely
refuses to use what should be the
profound knowledge of these people of
earlier societies to address the
problems of our own and and again ok
nobody really expects normally though we
always used to we always
used to think that being studying
history was the best possible
preparation for running politics I mean
if you if you think of the again looking
at bigger patterns the enormous
transformation of the West this this
this revolution that in which if you go
back to a particular moment of time from
which in virtually every way the world
gets better we know more we understand
more the sciences the arts develop it is
of course what we call the Renaissance
and what that was he was a historical
movement which consciously look back to
the last great the previous great
civilization that of Roman Greece and
tried to learn the lessons from it
and apply them to its own time and and
the fact because it coincided with a
technological revolution of printing it
succeeded and and did something
astonishingly remarkable but if we look
at more what we would now regard as more
and by the way just taking a point of
about history if you look at the the
great political leaders of the 16th
century and the great administrators
people like William Cecil in this
country they self-consciously see the
training that they've received in the
classics as fundamental to what they're
doing with their contemporary politics
which may give us a bit of ground with
hope with Burris because you're a big
semi serious he's a good crisis though
he didn't get it first I've never
forgiven for the world for the fact that
his contemporary David Cameron did but
you see we shift Graham to a subject
where we actually look and treat with
seriousness as running the world
economics modern economics has stopped
working why is it stopped working I
discuss it with my economics friends but
they die and I used to be a Tennessee
they don't seem quite to have caught on
yet economics a stopped working because
economics if you think why was it called
the dismal science in the 19th century
when it's largely invented because it
was all about managing scarcity but
things aren't scarce anymore except
toilet paper money aides guess which is
why you can find it the odd trillion
unit is a wonderful unit
Trillian - so in the back draw in other
words once once you would win the world
in which there's too much capital
hence interest rates of a quarter or if
indeed if you're in continental Europe
negative interest rates so banks charge
you to deposit money they don't pay you
for it they charge you for doing it and
the moment then you're in a world of
superfluity it's as though economics has
gone through the looking-glass you know
I mean it's no accident by the way that
the man who writes Alice in Wonderland
is a very important mathematician and
Charles Lutwidge Dodgson whatever and
and Louie otherwise known as Lewis
Carroll but he can imagine that world in
which you sort of reverse values I don't
think we've yet realized that that's
what we've done the astonishing
successes of modern capitalism create a
world in which all sorts of rules just
don't work anymore but we haven't yet
had a Maynard Keynes we haven't yet had
that store i stein those extraordinary
figures and what I think is most
striking is we are in this age of I
think a concentration of greater change
probably than two centuries and normally
those periods do produce extraordinary
figures you know you look at the
clusters of talent in Italy in there an
essence or something like that I don't
feel we have that at the moment I don't
feel there's anybody appreciating
understanding explaining what's going on
I don't see a figure as it were grasping
the changes in economy international
relation have you not been following the
lady Louise and these figures I mean
either silly I mean about how do you
find somebody is boring stop I mean just
I mean the sheer
t do ya it's not quite the Assembly of
great thinkers that you might otherwise
hopeful but one thing I wanted to talk
to you about David is what we've
discussed so what we've discussed the
left but on the right there seems to be
this craving not just in the US but
right across the world for the strong
man the powerful man the book you know
the populist leader why does that
suddenly arisen on us do you think that
desire for that for all the reasons
we've been talking about and if you get
a dissolution of certainty I mean we I
think we're sort of programmed I mean
remember if I go back to my original
historical work and it's on Royal Court
sits on monarchy the reason that I've
been a rebel
remember I'm talking about nineteen
sixties when I was a young man about do
research at Cambridge we all knew what
you had to study you just study the
working-class of the Labor Party or left
its movements and what the star could do
he comes along and says I believe that
the only thing that really matters is
aristocracy and monarchy and you can
look up the expressions on my teachers
faces and and I still believe that I
think that society is a run from the top
not the bottom all that happens is you
create new aristocracies Russia is a
very very nur these are very interesting
examples of this phenomenon and and that
essentially we and we are normally led
by bosses where we human beings have a
monarchical instinct
we made it approve of it but it's there
and your companies school we've also
live in hierarchy but it's not simply
hierarchy there's a boss figure that
nearly always and and what you what you
what you're looking at is ways in which
that boss figure is informed control
chosen the media through which he is
usually he or even worse when it's kind
of you know great she elephant like like
Margaret Thatcher happily not to resume
but again you see Teresa may illustrates
what happens when the boss figure goes
wrong
when you have somebody who doesn't have
this ability to command again with all
our caring sharing lovey dovey oh you
mustn't bore the people around oh no you
mustn't tell people what to do who
you're bullying you're bullying and you
human beings need occasionally at kick
up the ass
very often they need it very frequently
some people enjoy I mean I I'm not sure
I necessarily see it as a problem I mean
I think that that again the horrors of
what some people would claim is the last
episode of this of the interwar period
again that great period of instability
and in in in in in Europe and which of
course you know produces the horrors of
ours of Hitler and Stalin and and Moe
selenium whatever but people I think
leap to and make absurd comparisons
I don't think Trump in America and I
don't certainly think that Boris Johnson
here are remotely of that order they
share some similarities with it but what
is striking in Britain is exactly has
happened in the second world in in the
earlier 20th century and in Britain the
center has helped the two broad
political parties even despite the
catastrophe of the management of the
labor they hold together and the result
of that is of course they include the
extremes which are defined the again
people constantly that the left
you know denounce the wickedness of
first-past-the-post than wickedness of
the traditional British constitution but
it stops the development of extremist
parties and and you know they they a you
look at the complete failure of of of
you kid to do anything okay it colored
some aspects of Tory policy but you can
see how the fangs are drawn whereas the
great risk earner in Germany and is that
and I think it's a profound risk in
Germany when you've had a politics which
has been done it dominated by the
equivalent of a Tory labor coalition of
course the extremes benefit because
people get fed up particularly when it's
managed by somebody with you know a few
political talents as I think an uncle a
merkel is turning out to have so I'm I I
think that we should be looking much
more at the reality and nature of
political constitutions and here it
seems to me and I could be you know just
revealing my limitations as essentially
an English historian we benefit from
this extraordinary constitutional
stability eight hundred years it's
utterly unique ok the Japanese Empire is
longer but the constitution of the
Japanese Empire ain't continuous ours is
a broadly continuous Constitution and
safe for that brief episode of the 17th
century it has managed to control and
contain this and weave the country at
the same time that has modernized most
and changed most and yet we managed to
have a political structure which is
contained it and held it together and if
there's a historical lesson to be
learned I think that's it and you
mentioned the the Renaissance which i
think is an important question here
because I feel like very often when we
have these conversations with people
like yourself there's a temptation to
kind of go doom and gloom Z this is the
fall of the Roman Empire we're living
through the last days but it sounds like
what you're saying we have the the
capacity to recover from this what might
be a temporary malaise of a lack of self
confidence self hatred which it would be
nice to think so but again you see I
think the kernel of the comparison with
the Roman Empire is utterly false I mean
it has in theory is nice and flashy and
is easy to play with but remember the
reason of the Roman Empire well the
reason the Empire is creative the reason
the Republic Falls is the intervention
of the army now what is striking
I mean the Roman Empire's really the
army taking over the state and the boss
of the army you know Caesar and then
Augustus taking over the state there is
absolutely no sign of this in the West
at all not even in America well you have
this gigantic military complex the
generals not even with Trump show any
sign of wishing to do that we have
constitutional processes and I think I
think they are I think they are
profoundly important and the my anxiety
at the moment in the West is this it is
the obverse of the Renaissance the
Renaissance was that moment of
astonishing intellectual confidence of
course torment also but and again one
that was prepared consciously to draw
upon the past to transform the future
it's at a very early point it's phrase
wonderfully by geoffrey chaucer who has
this line and old books from which new
learning springs this wonderful
wonderful notion of the connection
between old and new and for me it's that
loss of that fructifying fertile quality
of history the as it were you have on
the one hand the mere conservator the
kind of old-fashioned National Trust
keep it all in a spec which separates
history from the present in that
direction and on the other the
neurologists the people who only believe
that's new what what you need in a
healthy culture is that dialogue of the
two the diet if you like the impossible
figure of the persons both a liberal and
a conservative but the real worry is
that we're losing that ability to have
dialogue oh well we certainly I mean how
well you put it I mean that the moment
that the moment that you get the the
sort of Twitter style or indeed
increasing the general political
discourse but enormous ly enormous ly
accelerated by the web and I I think
that that one of the great problems is
the
way in which the Weber's distorted that
with the web and social media have
distorted the very notion of
conversation and the very notion again
of a proper conversation in which there
will be different people with different
values I mean I had no idea what either
of you two thought you and more idea
what I thought and but each one of us
has been coming into this with bringing
what what what he has and neither was a
shouted at the other neither sirs got
indignant
nobody is denounced and this is the
model this is what I always believed in
passionately when I was teaching I
believe it's what universities should be
I believe there should be no authorities
and there are experts but experts aren't
always right experts are and they're
justified by evidence and that what we
need is it's this dialogue of civility
that we are having it's this willingness
to learn to engage to tease we've been
teasing the importance of humor the
importance of the smile the realization
that the most important issues are often
illuminated by that and the awful side
taking the polarization the shouting the
screaming and do you see are we really
saying we just need a recovery of good
manners I mean I think that one of the
reasons that and again tell me if I'm
wrong but one of the reasons that we
have become so shouty and so attached
around sides is there is a religion yes
yes I'm and therefore when when I
disagree with you I am NOT disagreeing
dr. David Starkey
I am disagreeing my blaspheming and I
say of course that's right I mean it is
again it's it's is why particularly the
politics of the left and isn't it
interesting the politics of the left
with the increasing fragmentation of
course replicate precisely what happened
to Protestantism you know that it splits
into smaller and smaller and smaller
groups
all of whom you're right like the
people's front of Judea in the Judea all
of who hate each other and you'll get
this immense vanity of small difference
the one thing that I think to use a
metaphor is a canary in the - humour and
when you see humour start to be that is
so unfunny people like Marcus Briggs
why does anybody think that people like
that a funny why I mean I think most
have been Hilton why is putting [ __ ]
Margaret Thatcher into the same sentence
something that we've got to laughing I
mean he's just it there is no wit there
is no lightness there's no fertility but
but do you think this this this mania
that we seem to descend it into for
taking a joke and then taking it
literally and then using that to attack
people as a sign of a problem within our
culture that we've lost the sense of
lightness the sense to laugh at
ourselves to really cook it ourselves
and ultimately to admit that we're human
yeah and that I'm I don't think we've I
don't think I don't think it's been
generally lost
I mean you listen to the banter on a bus
or in a pub it's what it's always been
but we have we have enabled the creation
of a public discourse of offense
victimhood and so on we you cannot have
a culture in which you know again
Voltaire in which oh my feelings we
don't have a duty to respect each
other's feelings in that sense we have a
duty clearly to an extent to care and
look after each other
but but that doesn't mean that every
sort of degree of snowflake fragility
has got to be recognized there needs to
be a robustness but equally I suppose
it's a question of a mutual confidence
it is I think it is essentially the
to victimhood which is so I think this
is where things have gone so appalling
me wrong
and again the day if occasion of
language that you know the whole
business of what it what is the
appropriate word to describe somebody
who is black and you actually look at
the sheer sensitivity of that issue I
mean for some people calling someone
black is is almost akin to calling the
n-word for other people in fact is
out-and-proud and that's what I am but
this this is this is this is these are
like the worst disputes of medieval
school men it's the Fetty it's fetishism
it's a fetishism of language and if you
have if you fetishize language in this
kind of way you can't have humor and you
can't even really use words we we
actually we really do stop talking to
each other well you don't know what the
right thing is to say i mean the the the
difference between a person of color and
a colored person the new c-word what 20
years ago i mean i remember one of used
to run a comedy club and i had an act on
who was black and an audience member
came up to me afterwards and he was so
happy about having seen this act and
said I remember his name the colored
chap and clearly to this person this
term was just a term that they're used
to using but my point is there was
absolutely no Malan event you know that
statement whatsoever and yet if you had
taken that conversation recorded it and
then played it on 9 a.m. BBC morning
breakfast show the complaints would have
fallen like rain fallen like storm
whatever and this is where this
distinction between ill intent and
prejudice and bigotry and simply using
failing to use the current horrible term
exactly but as I said I think this is
fetishism of language and it you know
the the last time you could see this
kind of thing and again it's wonderful
terrorized by-by Gibbon in the decline
and fall of the Roman Empire when
Byzantium was torn apart by the dispute
between homo Assam and homo II you see
on which are very different different
views of the deity and and and again
it's his fetishization of language I
mean it's quite literally this the city
Constantinople was half burned down in
the riots on this subject and what we do
about it I don't know again you see
there was a prophet in all of this and
we're not allowed to talk about him
and that's Enoch Powell and Enoch Powell
in his wicked speech no the one that is
always denounced and reacting to the
race relations act pointed out virtually
everything that we are now saying that
the moment you started entrenching this
notion of as it were a protected species
then it will become an instrument of
power he doesn't talk about he talks
about language to an extent but not
enough and I think that we are if we are
to recover and the the fate of trevor
phillips the man who in a sense started
all of this who was the the most
successful president of whatever used to
be called the race relations thing that
became equal whatever that he should now
as it were be pilloried for heresy it's
rather like the Middle Ages where you
know a pope is finally accused of heresy
we have to realize surely that that is
the moment at which we stop and if we
don't when
think about it this is this is V again
forgive me
the attack on Trevor Phillips seems to
me to be the moment at which the
revolution wants to guillotine Rob's
beer and the French at least had the
good sense to pause at that point we we
the left the guardian astir if they
cannot understand that well then
certainly they are lost perhaps the rest
of us needn't follow them on that note
David we've got time for one final
question for you which is always what's
the one thing that we're not talking
about as a society that we really should
be I'm going to repeat what I've said
because I think it is what is really
important the importance of the past not
as something to be fetishized not as
something to be National Trust eyes not
as something to be sentimentalized or
novelized like Hilary mantel but as
something that we genuinely try to
understand to enjoy to confront to use
and the I think the wisest figure in
English politics in English political
history
is Edmund Burke and the central lesson
of Burke is that society is a profoundly
organic thing he talks about it as being
a contract well that's the common
commonplace term of the social contract
but he formulates it in an extraordinary
way that it's a contract of past present
and future and are absurd this moment
ism breaks that contract and that is
precisely why it's been such a pleasure
to have you on the show because as I
said to you before we started were both
incredibly jealous of someone who
understands history because it gives so
many so many perspectives about what's
happening now and what may yet come so
thank you very much for coming on the
show David thank you for watching and
we'll see you again in a week's time
with another brilliant episode take care
see you next week guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word